please let us know about book fairs and
festivals in your area and we'll add
them to our list
email us at book tv at cspan.org
university of chicago political science
professor john mearsheimer is author of
the tragedy of great power politics it
outlines his worldview of offensive
realism and applies it to u.s china
relations the program runs an hour and
15 minutes
all clash well good afternoon ladies and
gentlemen i'm robert litvac i'm director
of international studies at the woodrow
wilson center and i'd like to welcome
all of you who are participating in
today's special event and to all of
those who are viewing this event via
c-span
the two main theories of international
relations are realism and liberalism
these competing theories offer
contrasting answers to such central
questions as how do we achieve
international peace
whereas realists focus on the
distribution of power between states as
the key factor
liberal theorists focus on the internal
organization of states
in academia
most of the great intellectual
battles among international relations
scholars take place either across the
divide between realism and liberalism or
within those paradigms
our speaker today john mearsheimer
is a party to this debate
he is i think it's fair to say an
undiluted realist
his path-breaking book the tragedy of
great power politics
just published by norton press and
available for purchase in the reception
following this meeting
has become an instant classic
a successor to eh cars the 20 years
crisis hans morgenthaus politics among
nations
and kenneth waltz's theory of
international politics
but the impact of this debate is not
merely academic
it has practical consequences for policy
as meersheimer observes
general theories about how the world
works
plays an important role in how
policymakers identify the ends they seek
and the means they choose to achieve
them
the history of american foreign policy
reflects the interplay and often the
tension between the contending realist
and liberal conceptions of international
relations
over the last decades the competing
pulls of realism and liberalism have
been reflected in the pendular swings of
u.s foreign policy
for example during the period of
superbarra de tant in the early 1970s
richard nixon and henry kissinger could
not sustain the domestic support for a
real politique
seemingly divorced from american
core values
jimmy carter subsequently
encountered the opposite problem of
liberal idealism uh running up against
uh the power realities of an assertive
soviet union
today's discussion takes place in the
context of the transformed international
environment precipitated by the
september 11th attacks on new york and
washington
it is perhaps particularly apt that a
discussion of the issues engaged by john
mearsheimer in his new book takes place
at the woodrow wilson center because
america's 28th president was perhaps
the leading practitioner of the liberal
school in the last century
the woodrow wilson center was created by
the congress as an affiliated agency of
the smithsonian institution to promote
interaction between the worlds of
learning and public affairs
so it is in that spirit uh let me
introduce our main speaker john
mearsheimer
and our commentator john eichenberry
who's another of this country's leading
academics in the field of international
relations
and also i might add a former woodrow
wilson center fellow
john mirsheimer is the r wendell
harrison distinguished service professor
and the co-director of the program on
international security policy at the
university of chicago where he's taught
since 1982.
he graduated from west point in 1970 and
then served five years as an officer in
the u.s air force
he then started graduate school in
political science at cornell university
in 1975 receiving his phd from there in
1980. he spent
the
1979-1980 academic year at the brookings
institution and was a post-doctoral
fellow
at harvard university's center for
international affairs from 1980 to 1982.
during the 1998-1999 academic year he
was the whitney h shepherdson
shepherdson fellow at the council on
foreign relations in new york
professor miersheimer has written
extensively about security issues and
international politics more generally
he has published two books conventional
deterrence which won the edward edgard s
furniture furnace
book award and little heart in the
weight of history
his current book is the tragedy of great
power politics which is published by
norton press he's also written many
articles that have appeared in academic
journals such as international security
and popular magazines such as the
atlantic monthly one in particular why
we'll miss the cold war appeared just as
the cold war was ending and really uh
helped set the debate on those issues
just as the cold war was ending
so it's it's
it's a double pleasure to
uh invite
to welcome
john mirsham to the woodrow wilson
center um
let me now introduce john eichenberry uh
who is the also
also to introduce john eichenberg who's
the peter crowe professor of geopolitics
and global justice at georgetown
university uh with an appointment uh
also in the school of foreign service
and the government department
he taught at princeton university from
1984 to 1992 and the university of
pennsylvania from 1994 uh to 2000 before
joining georgetown university he's held
posts in the
department of state's policy planning
staff he was a senior associate at the
carnegie endowment he's currently a
non-resident senior fellow at the
brookings institution
he received his phd from the university
of chicago where john mearsheimer
currently teaches in 1985 and as i
mentioned john eichenberry was a fellow
at the woodrow wilson center
just after we moved into these into this
new building in 1998.
he recently completed a book about the
politics of order formation after major
wars
a book entitled after victory
institutions strategic restraint in the
build rebuilding of order after major
wars which came out from princeton
university in 2001 and he's currently
editing a book that's particularly
appropriate for today's discussion on
american unit polarity and the future of
the balance of power
uh john mearsheimer
will take 30 minutes or so to lay out
the major arguments of his book that
will be followed by commentary by john
eikenberry to initiate dialogue
and a dialogue in which i would invite
those who are attending today to
participate so it's a great pleasure to
welcome john mearsheimer to the woodrow
wilson center john
[Applause]
thank you very much rob uh i have a bit
of a cold so if at any point in time i
wander away from the microphone and
anybody in the rear has difficulty
hearing me speak please just wave your
hand and i'll make the necessary
adjustments uh so that you can hear me
thank you very much rob for your kind
comments uh it's a great pleasure uh and
a privilege to be here uh at the wilson
center uh to speak to you folks about my
new book uh i would also say that i
greatly appreciate the fact that all of
you saw fit
to take time
out of your obviously busy schedules to
come out here today
to hear me talk
about the book
what i would like to do is three
separate things
although all three of these things will
be closely related this will become
apparent as i go along here first what i
want to do is lay out my basic theory of
international politics that tells you
why the international system is
basically a nasty and brutish place
and after i do that
i want to switch gears and i want to
talk about hegemony and exactly what
hegemony means now in the first part of
my talk when i tell you why
international politics is a nasty and a
brutish place i'm going to tell you the
great powers seek above all else
hegemony that's the outcome of my simple
theory okay again in the second part
what i want to do is sort of
operationalize to use social science
speak what i mean by hegemony what does
it mean to pursue hegemony in the modern
world
and the third thing that i want to do is
i want to shift to the subject of the
future of u.s chinese relations and talk
about what they're likely to look like
in the event that china continues to
econo to modernize economically in other
words it continues to grow
into a more powerful state economically
and i will argue militarily now it might
not seem at this point that all three of
those subjects are closely related but
as we go along here i think it'll become
manifestly apparent that that is the
case so back to the first subject which
is the question of why international
politics is a nasty and brutish business
where states seek hegemony my simple
theory
starts from what i think are five rather
non-controversial assumptions about the
structure of the international system
and what i argue is that when you take
those five simple assumptions you put
them into the blender and you hit the on
switch and you mix them up what you get
is a rather nasty world but by
themselves those five
assumptions
don't portray the world as particularly
competitive or com
or particularly brutish now what are the
five assumptions the first assumption
is that the international system
is dominated by states
and there is no higher authority that
sits above states yes there are
institutions like the united nations
uh there was once the league of nations
and these institutions do play some role
in international politics but they play
a minor role states are the principal
actors in the system and this system is
anarchic now when you use the word
anarchy people think you mean murder and
mayhem but as many of you know in
international relations that's not the
case to say that the system is simply
anarchic is to say that it has no higher
authority it's the opposite of
hierarchic so what we're saying is that
the international system is basically
comprised of states
that look like billiard bull balls on a
pool table right they have no higher
authority above them they are the
principal actors in the system that's
assumption number one
assumption number two
is that all states have some offensive
military capability now there's no
question that that military capability
varies from case to case but the fact is
that all states at all times have at
least some offensive military capability
so i like to say to people we usually
identify military capability with tanks
and aircraft carriers and guns but the
fact of the matter is that if you if
states were comprised of nothing more
than human beings
with loin cloths on as long as those
human beings had their feet and hands
they could walk across the border with
another state and use their hands to
kill people on the other side
for every nectar two hands to squeeze it
so the point is that states have some
offensive capability the third
assumption which is of great importance
is that states can never be certain
about the intentions of other states
in other words you can't be certain that
a state that
lives next door to you or lives
reasonably near to you at some point
down the road won't have malign
intentions
that's not to say you could be certain
that another state will have malign
intentions it's only to say that you
can't be certain that that state won't
have malign intentions for example
there's nobody in this audience who can
tell me what germany's intentions will
be in the year 2020 or what china's
intentions will be in the year 2020 or
even what america's intentions will be
in the year 2020. there's just no theory
no mechanism available to discern
intentions over the long run
to sort of emphasize this point from a
different perspective and it's a very
important point to grasp let me talk a
little bit about marriage and divorce
when people get married they almost
axiomatically assume that the person
they're marrying is wonderful
and that that person is going to be
wonderful forever
the fact that we have a 50 divorce rate
in this country tells you that that
assumption is not very sound the fact of
the matter is if you think about it
anytime you get married to someone it's
almost impossible to tell what he or she
is going to look like in terms of their
basic behavior towards you 20 or 30
years down the road the fact of the
matter is you may be marrying svengali
and just not know it and there is no way
you could figure out what your wife to
be or husband to be will look like in 20
or 30 years you can never be certain of
that person's intentions now that's not
to say you can be certain that you're
marrying a person who's going to turn on
you of course that's not the case my
only point is you can't be certain that
the person won't turn on you
first assumption is that the system is
anarchic it's comprised of states and
it's anarchic second assumption is that
states have some offensive military
capability and third is you can never be
certain about intentions fourth and
fifth assumptions are rather
straightforward fourth assumption is
that states are interested in survival
it's their highest goal this is not to
say states don't have other goals like
prosperity but their highest goal is
survival fifth assumption is that states
are basically strategic calculators
rational actors they are
pretty adept at coming up with clever
strategies for hit figuring out how to
survive in the international system
now those are the five assumptions and
as i said no one of those assumptions
that i've laid out says that the world
is highly competitive and that war is a
possible uh or a likely outcome
right
but when you take those five assumptions
and you put them into the blender and
you hit the on switch you get a very
competitive world to be more specific
you get three forms of behavior that
come right to the surface
first is that states fear each other
now why do states fear each other states
fear each other basically for two
reasons one they fear each other because
other states may have
hostile intentions to go along
with
their
offensive capabilities
and you can't be sure they won't come
after you in other words if you're
france and you live next door to germany
you can never be absolutely sure
right that the germany somewhere down
the road won't have hostile intentions
and build military forces and come after
you so that's one reason you're for fear
germany
the second reason that you fear germany
is the 911 problem
uh
this goes back to anarchy the fact of
the matter is that there's no higher
authority in the international system
that you can appeal to if you get into
trouble if you dialed 9-1-1 in
international politics you know who's at
the other end nobody
right
this leads to the second form of
behavior that results in this system
that i'm describing to you the first
being fear
second is that states quickly understand
that it's a self-help world god helps
those who help themselves in
international politics you can't rely on
other people to pull your chestnuts out
of the fire
because it just might not be in their
selfish interest when the money's on the
table for them to come to your rescue
and the end result is that you may end
up looking like france in 1870 or france
in 1940.
so the fact of the matter is that states
quickly decide that the best way to
protect themselves
is to protect themselves right and not
to rely on others
now the third form of behavior which is
the most important form of behavior that
comes out of this simple theory
is that the best way to ensure your
survival in the international system is
to be the most powerful state
in the international system to be the
hegemon to put it in more colloquial
terms the best way to survive in the
international system is to be the
biggest and baddest dude on the block
i'll get to this in a second but to get
ahead of myself
best situation you could possibly have
is to be the united states in the
western hemisphere how many of you
people go to bed at night worrying about
canada or mexico attacking us how many
of you worry about cuba or guatemala or
brazil or argentina attacking us the
answer is nobody worries about that why
because we are so powerful that none of
those states would ever think about
attacking us would you substitute a
situation where we had china on our
border and germany on our other border
of course not we liked the situation we
now have in the western hemisphere
perfectly well because we are by far the
most powerful state in the region
the basic line that i'm trying to get
across here is that the more powerful
you are
relative
to all of your potential adversaries the
more secure you are because it's highly
unlikely that they will come after you
now the fact of the matter is that every
great power in the system understands
the basic logic of this situation and
every great power strives to be the
biggest and baddest dude on the block
the end result of all this is that you
get security competition sometimes very
intense security competition among the
great powers
not in large part because great powers
are ativistic at heart or have malign
intentions but because in the
international system where you have a
significant 9-1-1 problem the best way
to assure your survival is to be the
hegemon in the system
but again everybody gets this message so
you get this constant competition for
power this constant competition among
the players to see who is going to be
the hegemon and be in the best position
to assure
survival
that's the basic theory
now i want to talk
more about the subject of hegemony and
this is the second part of my talk i've
made much to you about the fact
that states want to be the hegemon in
the system but i've not said very much
about what it means to be the hegemon in
the system
although there's much talk about being a
global hegemon
and dominating the entire globe i do not
believe it is possible for any one state
to dominate the entire globe to be a
hegemon across the entire face of the
earth
this is in part because of the sheer
distances involved but it's mainly
because of the difficulty of projecting
power across large bodies of water like
the atlantic ocean and the pacific ocean
so i would argue there's no way that any
single state can be a global hegemon the
best that you can do is that you can
become a regional hegemon you can
dominate your own particular region of
the world
and then make sure that no other state
on the face of the globe dominates its
region
the way you dominate your region
now
to illustrate this line of argument
let's talk about the united states
because i believe that this policy
reflects how the united states has acted
in the international system since the
very beginning and i believe by the way
it's a history that no americans or
hardly any americans appreciate in any
meaningful way so i want to lay it out
for you here very briefly because the
united states is the only example of a
state in the modern international system
that has achieved regional hegemony
other states have tried but they've
never succeeded the united states is the
only state that has succeeded the united
states also has gone to great lengths to
make sure that it has never had a pure
competitor and i'll talk a little bit
more about these things right
now if you go back to the beginning of
this country in 1776 we're basically
comprised of 13 measly colonies strung
out along the atlantic seaboard
by 1900 the united states was the
hegemon in the western hemisphere this
was the result of conscious policy
decisions from the beginning there were
two elements to our policy the first was
manifest destiny where basically we
decided that we would cross the entire
continent conquer huge portions of land
and build a super state called the
united states of america this was not
done by accident this was done on
purpose it was done for a lot of reasons
one of the main reasons was security we
wanted to make sure that we were very
big and we were very powerful and nobody
could threaten our survival and you want
to bet your bottom dollar when the time
comes that we cared very much about our
survival from the very beginning
think about how we gained our
independence in 70-76 think about the
fact that we fought the british in 1812.
think about the fact that there were
huge european empires in this hemisphere
when things first got started in the
late 18th century so the first thing we
did was we built a super state we
conquered huge amounts of territory
killed massive numbers of people
defeated other states in war then we
imported in huge numbers of immigrants
to fill the land we built a powerful
economy
furthermore we went to great lengths to
get the europeans out of this hemisphere
you all know about the monroe doctrine
in 1823 president monroe basically told
the europeans i'm not strong enough to
throw you out now but i want to tell you
loudly and clearly you're not going to
build any more empires in this
hemisphere and we're going to go to
great lengths over the course of this
century to throw you out of our
hemisphere because we don't want you
monkeying around in our hemisphere and
that's what we spent the rest of the
19th century doing
running those european empires out of
town
and by 1900 the united states was a
super state i think in terms of latent
military power the most powerful state
on the face of the globe and there were
no more european empires left in
our hemisphere we had established
regional hegemony and this was not done
by accident it was done on purpose
furthermore
the united states
spent most of the 20th century going to
great lengths to make sure that we had
no peer competitors around the globe
uncle sam under no circumstances is
willing to tolerate pure competitors
i'll tell you the basic story and
outline form imperial germany we went to
war in 1917 in my opinion because it
looked like germany was going to
dominate all of europe we helped cut
imperial germany off at the knees and
prevent them from dominating europe we
went to war against nazi germany in 1941
although we really began to spin up in
1940 with the fall of france because we
were fearful that nazi germany would do
what imperial germany tried to do and
failed we helped defeat nazi germany
imperial japan and asia threatened to
dominate all of asia the way germany
wanted to dominate all of europe we went
to war against them in 1941 and cut them
off at the knees when world war ii ended
it looked like the soviet union might
dominate all of europe we moved into
europe very quickly and we went to great
lengths to balance against the soviet
union very quickly we were aggressive
from the very beginning of the cold war
until the very end because we had no
intention of letting the soviet union
dominate eurasia just the way we had no
intention of letting imperial germany
nazi germany or imperial japan dominate
europe and asia the united states does
not tolerate pure competitiveness as far
as we're concerned we're allowed to be
the only pure competitor on the face of
the globe and the historical record is
quite clear on this point so that's what
hegemony means
now let me switch gears and talk about
china
the question of how you deal with china
now as you know in the clinton
administration and in the business wing
of the
republican party there's this widespread
belief in the land that if we make china
look like us
that we're not going to have any
problems with a prosperous or a wealthy
china down the road
the idea is if you get them hooked on
capitalism and you make them filthy rich
and you get them hooked on democracy and
turn them into a liberal democracy like
we are
and then you get embedded in all these
international institutions that we used
to be so fond of
uh
then we're not going to have any serious
trouble with these folks now why is that
the case
that's the case because they're going to
emulate us
and that means that
they're not going to cause any trouble
in the world because the united states
never causes any trouble in the world
all the trouble in the world is caused
by other people we're the good guys
right and if we could just make others
look like us we would all live happily
ever after and of course the basic story
put out by businessmen in the republican
administration and the clintonites was
that what we got to do is make china
look like us
these people have the story all wrong
if china gets wealthy it's going to look
like us
only it's not going to look like us the
way they think it's going to look like
us it's gonna look like us the way i
just described us to you in the past 10
minutes
and let me tell the story to you in a
bit more detail
if china
becomes a giant hong kong it's probably
going to have about four times the gross
national product of the united states
you understand at the height of the cold
war the soviet union had at most half
the gross national product of the united
states given the population disparities
between us and the chinese if they have
a per capita gnp that looks anything
like our per capita gnp they're probably
going to out distance us somewhere in
the range of three four maybe even five
to one
in terms of gross national product you
can build one heck of a lot of armor
division equivalents uh nuclear weapons
aircraft carrier battle groups with that
kind of uh
with that kind of gnp but of course the
assumption of liberals both in the
clinton administration and the bush
administration is
that china wouldn't do that right and
i say why wouldn't they do that why
wouldn't china emulate us if you're
china right if you're china don't you
want to be the hegemon in asia
don't you want your own monroe doctrine
don't you want to tell uncle sam that
he's not welcome
in your region of the world you
understand we have told the chinese
loudly and clearly they are not welcome
in our region of the world no no great
power is welcome to bring its military
forces into the western hemisphere you
all are old enough to remember how crazy
we used to go during the cold war during
the cold war when the soviets would put
military forces in cuba right
can you imagine
what we would do if the chinese began to
deploy military forces into a place like
mexico or cuba we would not like that at
all why do you think that china is going
to be enthusiastic about us
staying in asia with a large military
force once it has the capability to
dominate that region
i think it's highly unlikely that they
will be happy about that situation i
think they will go to considerable
lengths to dominate asia and to get us
out of asia the same way we went to
considerable lengths between
1776 and 1900
to dominate the western hemisphere again
this is not because i believe the
chinese or evil people or to put it in
different terms because i believe the
united states is filled with evil people
it's because the best way to survive in
an anarchic system where other states
may someday come after you is to make
sure that you are the biggest and
baddest dude on the block which when
translated into practical terms in
international politics means to make
sure that you dominate your region of
the world
you have no other state in your region
that can seriously threaten you
militarily and furthermore
across the rest of the globe there is no
pure competitor
that's dominated our foreign policy why
do you think it's not going to dominate
chinese foreign policy as china gets
more and more powerful i would argue
that china will behave that way
this brings us to the question of how do
you think the united states will respond
to this what is going to be the american
part of this story well i think the
evidence is quite clear on this the
united states has a rich record
of trying to cut off at the knees
any potential hegemon in either europe
or asia that looks like it might someday
be a pure competitor if we did not
tolerate
kaiser bill's germany adolf hitler's
germany tojo's japan or stalin's soviet
union as peer competitors why do you
think we will tolerate china as the
dominant force in asia the fact of the
matter is we will not we will go to
great lengths to contain them and to cut
them off at the knees just as we did
with those four other potential hegemons
that precede china in this hypothetical
situation
so the basic storyline that i'm telling
you
is that if china continues to grow
economically
which means it will have the wherewithal
to develop a mighty formidable military
capability
it will emulate the united states and it
will try
i believe to establish hegemony in asia
the way we have established hegemony and
the western hemisphere and the united
states on the other hand will go to
great lengths by forming an alliance
with japan
korea vietnam
india and russia just to name the main
partners to create a counter hegemony
coalition that can contain china and
hopefully over the long term
ruin it as a pure competitor because
again although americans don't like to
admit these things the fact of the
matter is we don't tolerate hegemons
anywhere else in the globe
but in the western hemisphere and here
we are the hegemon thank you
[Applause]
thank you john
thank you for not sugar coating it for
us uh
comment uh john would you i can very
would you like to take this dude
okay can you hear me
well my job is to help stimulate
discussion and just saying that it
sounds laughable really uh
i've known john for a long time and he's
never needed help in stimulating a
discussion but nonetheless i'll try to
make some general remarks
before we throw it open
first of all john has written a terrific
book
i think it's the most impressive and
important general statement of realist
theory
of international relations since kenneth
walt's 1979 book the theory of
international politics and i think it
will comfortably sit alongside that book
and other classics of the field
for some time to come and it will be
debated for some time to come and i
think that's
much to john's credit few books in my
experience have been able to
make both an academic theoretical
contribution and engage policy analysis
and weave in along the way
rich historical argumentation but john
really has done that
this is a book that both theorists
academics back in the university and
policy makers in washington and
beijing and elsewhere
will have to come to terms with one way
or another directly or or indirectly
moreover john reminds us of certain
basic realities about world politics
today
the book reminds us that the cold war
may be over but power and power politics
are still the coin of the realm
in international relations the remark by
the athenian military uh commander some
2500 years ago
that the powerful do as they will and
the weak suffer as they must is an
insight that certainly doesn't seem to
have lost any efficacy over the
centuries
secondly john reminds us that the
problem of power is still a central
problem for states today states still
worry about their security it's
remarkable how september 11th and the
attack on the united states transformed
the way this country acts and thinks and
that's to remind us that that
that security can be a transformative
and threats to security transformative
aspect of a country's existence security
dilemmas still exist declining states
still worry about rising states
alliances and power politics still
define the relations among major states
today thirdly john reminds us that great
powers still run the show as it were in
world politics uh globalization and
multilateral world system that is either
celebrated or reviled around the world
today certainly uh provocative what is
this new global order that's emerging
all of that rests on a foundation
hammered out by great power struggles
indeed it could be uh argued it's
certainly opened for debate that the
postwar international
uh economic juggernaut that emerged
after world war ii and today defines uh
a great part of what we we know uh to be
world politics today the open system of
trade and investment really would not
have been possible without that great
power order that was hammered out in the
during the cold war the united states
securing allies building
predictable alliances across the
eurasian rimland as john suggests making
sure that no one state along that rim
land was a hegemon that that could
challenge the united states
finally john john's book reminds us that
great power wars are still possible they
aren't simply
overruled by
by the end of the cold war it may be
true as
some of our colleagues such as robert uh
jervis at columbia who have argued that
it is stunning that we have we now are
living in the longest period of
the absence of great power war where two
great powers have directly confronted
each other in in modern history uh that
is remarkable of course the cold war
bipolarity nuclear weapons have a lot to
do with that but nonetheless john
reminds us that war could still happen
perhaps most
likely would be the u.s china
conflict maybe over taiwan
now john's most challenging argument
of course is his central thesis that
anarchy forces states not simply to
search for security
but to continuously and aggressively
search for ways to expand their power
and deny the same to others
john shows and the book is wonderful in
this regard in showing that this
offensive impulse uh to aggressively uh
calculate and expand one's power is
shaped and mediated by a variety of
factors geography the fact that britain
and the united states with their
offshore position have done things
differently thought about power
differently ideology and national
tradition the the liberal tradition in
america this is one reason that john uh
concludes that perhaps the united states
doesn't quite get it in terms of china
because we have this liberal tradition
that sometimes sees engagement as the
the way to go
that is a statement about the power of
something that goes beyond simply power
calculation the kind of ideological way
of looking at the world the united
states possesses we might think about
how that matters the
authenticity and the accuracy of that
those ideas but they certainly matter
technology and as john suggests wherever
possible buck passing that is to say to
find states that will do your bidding
for you that within the region will
provide that basis for for balancing a
rival
but john despite these nuances uh uh
gives us a very clear and distinct
message that anarchy still shapes great
power politics that security competition
is important and intrinsic and inherent
in the international system and that
there are no that is to say there are no
uh status quo powers in world politics
today so let me just raise a few
questions about this quite strong
position
as it relates to the pattern of great
power politics today really three
questions or observations first of all
for parts of the world today the old
great power world
within this old great power world the
west and japan anarchy
doesn't seem to be what it used to be it
is quite remarkable i would argue that
the end of the cold war did not trigger
the type of return to strategic rivalry
among europe the united states and
america's allies in in asia particularly
japan throughout the 1990s uh many
realists and theorists of the balance of
power have anticipated the unraveling of
relations among these major great states
germany and japan would rearm
nato would decay the u.s japan alliance
would weaken security competition would
creep in regional block mentality would
emerge multilateralism would unravel
that is to say generally speaking what
we anticipated was the problems of
anarchy to reappear the return of hyper
nationalism armed races and most
importantly balanced power politics of
the most most uh most uh a
sharp kind uh security competition among
the major states
yet none of this happened at least not
yet europe
united states and japan have no common
enemy the cold war disappeared the
bipolarity disappeared the balance of
power has gone through the most dramatic
re reshuffling and transformation in the
last century yet without those
that external threat and with those
major transformations at the level of
the distribution of power during the
1990s these countries reaffirmed their
alliance partnerships retained and
restrained political con conflict
expanded traded investment across the
pacific and the atlantic and avoided the
return to great power balance of power
rivalry indeed relations among the
advanced states or what i would call the
old great powers are roughly what
they've been for four or five decades
the end of the cold war was an overrated
world historical events the event these
countries are basically doing and
behaving the way they have for half a
century they have among themselves
europe the united states japan
built an order that's remarkably stable
multilateral reciprocal legitimate
loosely hierarchical not simply
anarchical and and loosely uh
institutionalized carl deutsch uh can
sleep easy at night uh war among these
countries is still unthinkable moreover
the strategic competition has persisted
despite the rise of what the french call
american hyper power
paul kennedy had a wonderful essay in
the financial times a week and a half
ago when he was
spotlighting what i think we all know
namely that the military distribution of
power has become more quote unquote out
of balance than it has been in modern
history he calls it stunning
unprecedented uh something that staggers
the mind the united states military
spending is equal to the next nine
countries combined and it's getting
larger the the increase for next year's
military budget between this year and
next year is larger than any one uh
absolute level of any one european
security budget today twice that of
italy
when you add high tech the asymmetry is
even greater
and when you add economic and the other
aspects of power asymmetry the gap
between number one and number two is as
wide as it's been for several centuries
yet europe and japan are not loosening
their ties they're not calculating this
is a world we can't live in after all
it's a world of anarchy and relative
power and we are losing ground we need
to
dramatically reshape our security
budgets and our strategic postures to
make sense of what is the most dramatic
strategic shift in in in the global
landscape that we have seen uh in in
really a generation or two yet these
countries have not articulated such a
strategic pathway
i know john argues in his book that
japan and germany are not great powers
today because they do not have the kind
of autonomous military power that would
qualify them to be in the great power
club that may be true they certainly are
eccentric great powers they are what
they would probably call civilian great
powers uh they are
semi-sovereign in that respect but my
question is why
have they chosen to play this this this
role why have they chosen to remain
neutered or
semi-sovereign when they have choices
certainly given their wealth and the the
kind of
political structures they have they can
make these decisions why have they
decided as john has suggested the
structure of anarchy propels all states
to try to be the biggest and baddest
state on the block uh they haven't done
this they are in fact looking like they
are charting a very different kind of
path for whatever reason and i'm not
suggesting at the moment that
that that it's it's uh it's out of
john's framework to explain some of this
this may be to use his framework uh a
kind of
buck passing with a vengeance that is to
say these countries are
allowing the united states to provide
their security but look at germany
germany has found a way to
to not if not
totally resolve the question of
intentions which is the the basic
problem that leads anarchy to offensive
realism that we don't know what these
states are going to look like in 20
years that's true but there are
variations in those uncertainties and
germany certainly looks different today
than it did in the 1930s
when france looks at it the way in which
it has bound itself to its its neighbors
for very security realist type reasons
starting with coal and steel community
and even when germany did what uh
bismarck was doing a hundred years
earlier that is to say expanding germany
the enlargement the unification of
germany it did what what history and
realism tells us that made thatcher and
mitteron very nervous but what did
chancellor cole do he uses a he used a
strategy really of trying to
reduce that uncertainty about intentions
by by agreeing to accelerate it's the
binding a
willingness to bind itself to the rest
of western europe through the european
monetary system so my message here
really is there are security strategies
that have emerged in the west among
these democracies that has allowed for
the the rough edges of anarchy to at
least be
to to be uh
softened if you will even if not
overturned secondly china and russia
today seem to pose a variant of the same
puzzle
shouldn't russia and china be pursuing
more aggressive counter-balancing
strategies now we all know when putin
and zhang jimin get together they
complain of american hegemonism if
that's a term but then they go back and
make choices that look to be very
different from
doing what i think if they were they
were seriously pursued such an alliance
we'd say yeah that makes sense the
united states is this powerful country
and history tells us they should be
balancing against it it's good
old-fashioned anarchy balance of power
logic but they aren't doing that at the
very least they're pursuing a more mixed
strategy
now russia of course is providing the
most interesting
experiment in strategic thinking putin
is using september 11th in america's
interest in alliance partners to fight
terrorism to to wiggle himself into this
western framework and there's even talk
at least in some circles about a more
concrete institutional affiliation with
nato that's really interesting that
looks like
binding rather than balancing
tom christensen the the china scholar
argues that if if russia really succeeds
in this china is going to want to get
into that club as well this doesn't mean
that balanced power thinking or let's
say great power politics is going to be
uh diminished because great power
politics is inherent in the fact in the
the presence of great powers but but
accommodation and integration uh is at
least one logic that looks to be coming
out of out of uh russia and china so the
question really is are these two great
powers
lying in weight that is to say saving
their powder keeping their powder dry
for another day when they're stronger or
has the structure of relations changed
again not uh a a overturning of anarchy
but but a
changed strategic environment where
democratic great powers wealthy and
satisfied combined with nuclear weapons
which john has not talked a lot about
but which i think changed great power
politics in a very important ways
made security con competition more less
intense and more manageable it's
difficult to answer this question uh my
answer may be different than john's but
the answer to this question will tell
you a lot about the the the true
character and underlying logic of
international order today
finally a question about the stability
of america's extended security
commitment john has articulated
that without a pure competitor in europe
and and and asia the united states will
eventually pull its forces out of these
regions this in turn will trigger a
return to regional competition and it
will return be
a return to the kind of great power
politics that we we know perhaps from
the 19th century
john acknowledges that america's
security presence in europe and japan
are forces of stability in those region
yet he argues and has said so uh quite
clearly that without that pure
competitor uh the interest in in staying
in in those regions will not not be
there so it's really a question of
whether the united states has a an
interest in staying in those regions
inside the beltway it seems to me that
the consensus is that
the security and stability of those
regions which hinge on america's
presence at least now is something that
the united states uh wants to factor
completely into its foreign policy the
nye report of 1995 kind of was the the
consensus document on that so at the
very least to conclude i think that
john's thesis and book should trigger a
healthy debate on the logic and future
of a u.s commitment and this larger
far-flung
world order to end let me say
the book is terrific when i think about
the tragedy of great power politics i
think i i i think that it's possible to
locate or identify two meanings of
tragedy the greek notion of tragedy is
it's a pity it had to be that way that
is to say we are doomed to conflict uh
and it's the tragedy of the structure
this is john's position the jew there's
a different view of tragedy the
judeo-christian view of tragedy which is
it's a pity it was that way because it
didn't have to be that way
as a liberal i tend to see a lot of
international conflict uh
in the second way it's a second kind of
tragedy but john reminds us that there
are deeper and perhaps enduring sources
of conflict that go beyond it
thank you
thanks very much john
let's open it up now for comments
and uh questions from the floor if
speakers could please identify
themselves and we have
microphones that can be passed
gentlemen
on my right
i thought i was going to be second um
chuck woolery with the world federalist
association
uh i really appreciate i look forward to
reading your book i really appreciate
the five assumptions that you've listed
i want to suggest a sixth assumption
that maybe explains the problems that
we're in and that is the sixth
assumption being that we we still
believe that nation states can protect
us as individuals
that it appears after 9 11 that no
matter how big a military you have if
someone wants to get to you if they're
going to get to you and with biological
weapons being the flip side of nuclear
threats that they're increasingly so
um
when you look at the threats that we
face now they're not so much from nation
states they're environmental threats i
would say infectious diseases are a very
significant threat
international crime other forms of
threats that we face as individuals and
not so much as nations
i wanted to get your perspective on the
thesis that
robert mundell the recent recipient of
nobel prize in economics put out
uh regarding uh the three ideas of
free-flowing currency
currency stability
and independent currency policy he
basically said you can't have all three
of those at the same time
freedom security and independence
the nation-state system is built on the
idea of independence
yet it seems like if we consist on that
we're going to have to give up our
freedom or our security in either one
any of these many different areas that i
just talked about
respond to that
if if speakers could please remain
seated we'll pass the microphone to you
rather than you have to come up to the
to the
john yeah that's an excellent question
and uh i wish i had an hour to respond
to it but let me give you sort of the
brief answer
first of all i think that the nation
state
is not perfect when it comes to
protecting the members
of
of that state but i think it does a very
good job
and
i think if you're interested in
surviving as a people
in the world today
there's simply no substitute for having
your own state
and i think
the best example to highlight is the
this is the arab-israeli conflict
the palestinians desperately want their
own state and they want a viable state
and they want a powerful state because
they've come to recognize that the only
way they're ever going to live a decent
life is to have a meaningful state the
jews on the other hand learned
the hard lesson
over the years that if you don't have
your own state you die in large numbers
at the hands of those who do have states
and therefore they created this ideology
called zionism and then they marched
into the
middle east and they carved out a state
and although they don't have perfect
security today i would
argue that they're a heck of a lot
better off in terms of survival today
they than they were uh when they were
living
in europe in the 19th and early 20th
century
so i think there's just no substitute
for having your own state for surviving
in this world
the question of whether or not
freedom and security
don't go along with independence and you
defined independence as having a
sovereign state
i really don't buy that i don't think
that the nation state is the end all in
be all and i'm not terribly happy about
the world that we live in but given that
i'm a realist with both a capital r and
a little art you make do with what you
have
and i think that
the state if it's put together properly
and if it acts intelligently
can go a long way towards providing
security for its people
and providing freedom for its people
and i don't mean to be overly
chauvinistic in
talking about the united states
uh in favorable terms but i do think
that the united states which is a
powerful nation state does a pretty darn
good job of providing for our security
and providing for our freedom this is
not to say for one second that there
aren't threats out there that we from
time to time can't deal with september
11th being a perfect case in point
but i think all things considered it's
not a bad deal
david shambaugh who's a china expert at
george washington university
well thanks rabbi you saved me from
introducing myself um
well and john thank you first of all for
a wonderful book which i had the
pleasure of reading over the christmas
holidays and i looked forward in the
book to the discussion of china
and honestly was rather disappointed
that there was as little discussion of
china in the book as there was and i was
quite intrigued this morning
to hear the time that you spent on china
and
as such i'd like to direct my comment
and question if i can to that element of
your your
presentation
because it troubles me it troubles me
deeply as a china specialist
and let me tell you why uh if i can
briefly for maybe three three reasons
first on the economic part of your
argument
it assumes a straight-line trajectory of
growth
it extrapolates from per capita growth
uh to
or maybe backwards from aggregate gdp to
per capita growth but in your
presentation you said you know what what
if we have 1.3 billion
chinese who are have per capita annual
income of 40k a year at least that was
the assumption
that's not the china i know and i doubt
we'll ever see in our lifetimes
it also ignores the internal weaknesses
in china and the great potential for the
whole china modernization project to go
off the rails
okay thirdly it ignores
china's traditional military deterrence
theory which is one of minimum
deterrence
and balanced allocation of resources to
the military establishment vis-a-vis the
rest of the
economy
so that's the first sort of set of
difficulties i have secondly
i don't think it quite understands
chinese history um
the philosophical basis of chinese
statesmanship and particularly the role
that hegemony plays in chinese thinking
you will find the term ba
in chinese vocabulary before you will
find the word hedge in greek
it goes back to the 4th century bc it is
something the chinese have discussed
ever since
and it is fundamental to their thinking
about international affairs and it is
the cinequan non of contemporary chinese
foreign policy that is to say
fanba
anti-hegemony
and they are against it in a generic
sense not just because the united states
and therefore practices it
this is rooted very much in the century
and a half of their so-called shame and
humiliation this is a country that has a
deep insular psychology
that has been subjected to hegemony over
a very long period of time
and has a it certainly is a is a
nationalist country we know about that
but i would submit to you it's what i
call defensive nationalism rather than
aggressive nationalism
um thirdly i don't think you quite uh
defined very well chinese dominance of
asia or hegemony over asia as you
predict it
i find the argument much to zero sum
what about japan what about india what
about russia and who why should you
assume the united states is going to
pack up and go home
just because the chinese want to assert
their hegemony over the region
and last point i would make is the u.s
policy towards china the project i mean
i will grant you very much it's that
it's not just the republican business
community
and the clinton
liberals uh who have had a missionary i
call it the missionary impulse to
transform china and america's image this
goes back to the 1860s
we've had a long-standing
attempt in this country to try and do
that it's not about to end anytime soon
but i would submit to you for the sake
of this discussion that it's a strategy
of co-optation not preemption and not
containment and from nixon through the
six subsequent administrations and we
have a president going to china next
week
who now articulates the same line of
arguments about integration of china
into the international system and
engagement of china
to try and build interdependencies
between the united states and china
this is not a strategy of preemption or
prevention or much less containment so
those are my observations i don't think
it holds water
when it comes to china my question for
you is why can't the co-optation
strategy if you want to call it that
work
why would the united states abdicate
east asia to china and why don't the
interdependencies between the united
states and china which are increasingly
deep 120 billion dollars in annual trade
just to name one
why won't that why won't that ensure a
less zero-sum future
the problem with those questions is that
there are so many of them uh they have a
whole session just on that yeah i could
have a whole session so i'm gonna go
very quickly yeah first of all i was
assuming that china will grow
economically into a giant hong kong
you're correct to point out that that
might not happen for economic reasons
and maybe even for political reasons
maybe the country will fragment and
break apart
i was just assuming that it did continue
to grow economically and then ask what
would be the consequences of that
from my point of view i hope it doesn't
grow economically and i hope it doesn't
turn into a jug or not
it was just an assumption
with regard to
the history of china
first of all i don't really care that
much to be honest about the history of
china because i'm a structuralist right
and i believe that the structure of the
situation dictates how you behave
and
my argument is that yet china has not
been very aggressive recently but that's
hardly surprising because it's been a
paper tiger
since at least the middle of the 19th
century and if anything it's been the
victim of aggression uh by great powers
like japan
and the sov and russia slash the soviet
union they've been the victim
this is why they are real poly takers
par excellence
there are two countries in the world i
can go to where i'm really among my
people one is china and the other is
israel
these are countries that understand
mocked politique right because they know
what it's like to be at the bottom of
the dung heap
but but again my argument is that
you want to hypothesize a world where
china has
lots of power lots of economic and
military might and then begin to think
about how it will behave and you know
what my structural arguments are but let
me say a few words about history i think
that with all due respect david you have
the history all wrong i have a graduate
student a chinese graduate student who
just finished a dissertation for me
that looked at the behavior of the great
chinese empires over time and they were
as interested in hegemony as any
european empire i've ever laid eyes on
right this is an area that has a rich
history
of aggressive behavior by the biggest
powers in the area seeking to achieve
hegemony uh for anybody who's interested
i can give you afterwards the name of
this student he's now a postdoc at
harvard and you get a copy of his
dissertation from him which is a
first-rate dissertation which shows
quite clearly that the chinese for good
structural reasons in the past have
behaved much the way the europeans have
behaved and much the way the americans
have behaved
one final point i was not arguing that
the united states would pack up and go
home if china becomes an economic and
military juggernaut on the contrary i
was arguing that
if china shows any signs of looking like
the former soviet union or imperial
germany the united states will quickly
cobble together a balancing coalition to
prevent that from happening now you
believe like many china specialists that
this would be a terrible thing because
we should really engage them
and hopefully we'll all live happily
ever after there's one fundamental
problem with your argument and that is
that you have no way of being able to
tell me what chinese intentions will
look like in the year 2020 or in the
year 2030. so from an american
perspective you're talking about
creating let's put it slightly
differently helping to create a
juggernaut
with which you can't tell me how it will
behave
this to me is not a smart policy i do
not create juggernauts unless i am
absolutely certain that they won't come
after me and no chinese specialist
despite all his or her knowledge about
the subject has ever come up with a way
of telling me what chinese intentions
will look like in the year 2020. given
that fact i say let's contain them now
i want to
break in a few minutes to go to the
reception where we can continue this uh
dialogue but i'm going to take two more
questions of bob lieber from georgetown
university first
in
walters um a two-part question and also
let me add my voice to those who
having read the book see it as a real
masterpiece
my questions though are are twofold
one
about the revolution in military affairs
an important part of your book which you
did not touch on at length in the talk
it has to do with the stopping power of
water which you then relate to the
notion that becoming a global hegemon is
a very very difficult if not impossible
my question is in light of the rma
whether that assumption needs to be
re-examined and somewhat connected to it
is to ask your your thoughts about the
post september 11th world the last
portion of your talk as the last portion
of your book focused on the subject of
the united states and china over the
long term
but in view of the dramatic and
even traumatic events of september 11th
and the
major
perhaps reconceptualizing of american
grand strategy by the bush
administration i'd be curious to hear
your thoughts about that subject
uh thank you for your kind comments bob
about the book and for other people as
well especially john for all his kind
words
uh first on the revolution in military
affairs
i have never been too sure exactly what
the revolution in military affairs is
number one and number two i'm never too
sure whether it's happened
is happening or is about to happen
but uh having said all those things i
kind of guess it means that all these
precision guided munitions
uh that we use
uh in places like yugoslavia
in 1999 in afghanistan have
revolutionized warfare and have given us
tremendous power
that we heretofore did not have
now
i think that precision guided munitions
really do matter
and i don't want to say that they're
insignificant
but i think that taking the united
states air force and going up against
yugoslavia or the taliban
and you know beating the stuffing out of
them doesn't really tell you too much
about how powerful you are
you know this is like the vermont
against the apaches it's just not really
a fair fight
and i wouldn't read too much into what
happened in afghanistan i would also
note that the pentagon and the bush
administration in general have just not
given us a lot of information about how
that war played itself out
and i'm one of these people who likes
lots of facts and likes to see the whole
story before i make up my mind on
exactly how important particular weapons
are or particular military strategies or
doctrines are in winning wars
and
i wouldn't be surprised if when all said
and done that we conclude that air power
really did matter greatly in afghanistan
but not as greatly as we thought in
november and december and maybe even
today i mean i may be wrong on that but
i want to see more information but again
my bottom line is that if you're really
interested
in dominating other countries and
dominating other regions you do it with
armies you can't do it from the air and
you can't do it from the city it's again
not to say that the air force doesn't
matter and the navy doesn't matter but
if you really wanted to dominate
afghanistan and you really wanted to win
the war in afghanistan which we did not
do you would have sent in ground forces
and you would not have lost the battle
at tora bora the way we did because we
didn't have sufficient ground forces
there right you need armies to conquer
and dominate regions air forces can help
but armies matter the most even in light
of the rma
with regard to the post september 11th
world
i think that there's no doubt that the
terrorist attacks of september 11th lie
outside the scope of the book it's not
about great parapolitics in fact this
terrorist organization al qaeda is a
transnational actor right it doesn't fit
really anywhere into my theory but i
think that the effects of 911 on the
geopolitical structure will be on the
margin
getting back to john's comments on my
book i do believe that nato was in
trouble before september 11th i believe
there was a lot of evidence to that
effect
i believe that as a result of 9 11 nato
will be in increasing trouble the the
centrifugal forces that were at play
before 9 11 will be exacerbated by what
happened and
on september 11th and the policies that
we've adopted afterwards but i don't
think it's going to lead to any
fundamental changes and the u.s china
problem that i've talked about here
today still remains on the table and it
could be that 10 years from now we're
much more concerned about china than we
are about terrorism or that we're
equally concerned about both threats
because again it's not an either or
situation
just to pick up on john ikenberry's
comment uh
would perhaps you could elaborate on on
picking in the menu of issues he raised
one of his key points was sort of why
didn't
the world balance the united states at
the end of the cold war in the way that
realist theory uh would uh predict
yeah john raised a number of uh
excellent points and being the smart guy
that he is he sort of zeroed in on what
are all the
potentially weak points in my argument
and i wish i had uh at least a half hour
to deal with them one by one
let me just deal with two points
picking up on rob
first of all i think that the reason
that europe looks so peaceful today and
in fact asia looks so peaceful today is
you have a hundred thousand american
troops sitting on top of europe and a
hundred thousand troops sitting on top
of asia and in fact those hundred
thousand troops in europe are sitting on
top of germany which in terms of latent
power is the potentially most powerful
state in europe in japan which is
potentially the most powerful state in
asia at this point in time the united
states sits on top of them as well
nobody has any elbow room everybody is
basically in a straitjacket except the
russians and the chinese who are in no
position to contest uncle sam as long as
he remains firmly in place in europe and
asia so i don't think you have a lot of
security competition in either one of
those regions in large part because the
american pacifier is there this leads to
rob's question which of course is the
point up point that john raised which is
why hasn't anybody balanced against us
nobody balances against us because we're
not out to be a global hegemon right we
are an offshore balancer
right
there's much talk and
uh john i mentioned the paul kennedy
piece in the financial times which i
read which is an excellent piece but you
read that piece and you read a lot of
the uh papers stories in the papers
these days and listen to people talk
there's this sort of tendency to
describe us as a global hegemon
we're not a global hegemon we're a
hegemon in the western hemisphere and
we're an offshore balancer in other
regions and that's why people are
basically willing to tolerate us in
those regions because they know we're
not going to dominate those regions if
you talk to the europeans today the
europeans main concern is that nato is
fragmenting its fracturing the united
states is losing interest in europe it's
going to pull troops out of europe and
it's going to send them to fight the war
on terrorism or send them to fight a war
against asia they're not worried about
us dominating the european continent
they're worried about us going home it's
like the russians and the chinese
another excellent point that john raised
although i do think not surprisingly
that i have a response to john why
haven't the russians and the chinese
shown
much evidence that they're going to come
together against the united states
because we're not threatened to conquer
either one of them and furthermore
because they basically share a border
and have all sorts of problems between
themselves they understand that they're
more likely to go to war with each other
than they are to go to war with the
united states the offshore balancer so
that's the argument i would make as to
why there's been no balancing against us
thanks john uh
last question to professor walter rice
from george washington university thank
you it's a
well let me say that i'm
i'm delighted that i haven't yet read
your book john because i have the
pleasure
of looking forward to it
but i just want to understand how
radical a structuralist you are
you describe a situation
in which things are inevitable
sort of like when you catch a cold
your immune system is unless it's sick
is going to attack whatever is causing
your cold
does it make does it not make a
difference who runs a particular state
does it not make are they are states
always going to behave
uh in a certain way because of the
structural system as if they've already
read your book
are things so inevitable
that's the cleavage right there in the
debate so john yeah
well first of all i think and i think
john alluded to this in his uh comments
that i am about as pure structuralist as
you'll find on the face of the globe
there's just not much question about
that
uh i have no way of saying how much
structure matters compared to sort of
domestic politics or who the individual
is who is in charge
of american or german foreign policy at
any particular point in time
but i do believe that domestic politics
um and uh and in the individual behavior
uh does not matter very much uh the case
that's usually
uh a deuced to sort of uh challenge me
on this point is the question of adolf
hitler right
doesn't adolf hitler prove that
individuals do matter
and my response to that is
yes
in the sense that adolf hitler brought a
murderous ideology along
with his
traditional german balance of power
behavior i don't deny that for one
second
so therefore having adolf hitler in
charge in germany in world war ii did
matter when you compare it to having
kaiser bill in charge in germany in
world war one and otto von bismarck in
charge in germany between 1864 and 1870
when prussia waged the three wars of
german unification from the
point of view of all that murderous
behavior yes it did matter that you had
adolf hitler in charge
however the point that i would make is
it is still highly likely that you would
have had world war ii without adolf
hitler if someone else had been in
charge i would remind you you had world
war one without adolf hitler kaiser bill
was in charge you had the german wars of
unification without adolf hitler
furthermore if you look at german
behavior
during the weimar period the country was
filled with
decision makers and
policy intellectuals who had a highly
aggressive view of what german foreign
policy behavior should be
so my bottom line is that individuals do
matter
on the margins
but by and large
right by and large states behave in
rather heavy-handed and cold and
calculating ways towards each other and
i think by the way this is especially
true of the united states but what the
united states has is it has this whole
stable of spin doctors who come out and
justify all of our cold and calculating
behavior in very idealistic rhetoric
which the american people just gobble up
because we all want to believe that
we're the good guys and everybody else
is the bad guys you go outside the
borders of the united states you go to
asia you go to europe and you talk to
people about what they think about
american mock politique they think the
united states is a very heavy-handed and
in many ways a very nasty country in
terms of its foreign policy behavior i'm
not condemning that by the way my point
is that that's the way you have to
behave in the international system to
survive same is true with a country like
israel israel is a really tough nut
these people you know
they really uh
act according to the dictates of
offensive realism and they do it because
they're interested in surviving in a
nasty neighborhood same thing is true
with india despite all this talk about
mahatma gandhi and
peaceful
uh protests and so forth and so on the
indians have consistently behaved like
the israelis like the americans like the
british in a very heavy-handed kind of
way very much according to the dictates
of realism but our great advantage in
this world the great advantage all four
of those countries have is that they
have terrific spin doctors
well this john this has been a terrific
exchange the book is the tragedy of
great power politics by john professor
john mearsheim of the university of
chicago available through norton press
thank you john mearsheimer thank you
john ikebere for an outstanding
commentary and please join me in
thanking our speakers today for a
terrific session
now i would invite you all
i invite you all to join us
for a reception just across the hall in
the boardroom
john mirsheimer is author of the tragedy
of great power politics it's published
by norton visit www.norton.com
for more information
you're watching book tv